ten town and we're going to the war zone
it's pretty far from here so we're going
to go all night in the most dangerous
thing which we can face could be snipers
and ambush we'll have to check the
situation for our safety
it's like Christmas Christmas parcel
signed for a hero
epica picture with a beautiful woman to
make soldiers athletically
the your army my done is our first name
but we change it Muslims for the arm of
Ukraine nine months ago we understood
that our army is really hopeful
condition they don't have a quick man
they don't have cars then they have food
and when tears start to change to help
to support in total for this period we
erased like 1.3 million dollars you know
in our country volunteering and charity
with such sizes yeah it's an unusual
that's really what we couldn't believe
possible happen because people and army
work together for one common aim we are
helping each other to fix not to kill
each other but to fix
everydays there is a big big fires near
the Donetsk Airport that's why we have
to check where where we can go now we
have too old to wear the safe jackets
and helmets for our sku EG
lets you down radam easy switching of us
aleksandra ifc a company mom was not her
daughter doha's dalida so guys let's
start is now a Smotrich mother sliding
conserving made in Russia we talked with
Maxim by phone and she tell us what they
need shoes uniform medicaments
medicaments right Stalin small cooler
now sneaker products to select Roberta
Emerson cisterna Silva near his name of
rewards up straily
just as when you as abuse Nathaniel
yes could I yeah I know enjoy a
dangerous area especially for stay here
more than one hour when it will be dark
so we need to finish everything very
fast can go to the way now I'm going on
let's go work making pictures girls man
you're dead
doc check I've insisted on
no it's a koala move this morning I
never knew her dance in the truck yes
infant Achilles fountain s okay
I know that
just got a phone call from unknown woman
she she told that even the guy in you
and the idea and from the military's so
I know him for a long time I just got a
phone call that he died yesterday NSAC
yesterday we were in a labor city with
the city where he died when yesterday
day it happens yesterday so we were like
five key holders 30 the place it was
very funny like very gentle you know it
was very professional to do tacos
Youkilis icon was very smart you know
yeah we just met two three weeks ago
looking down we were dancing on the
track and it was five kilometers from
the place where he died
I'm sorry
the debaltseve it's like a city which is
surrounded all the sides by separatists
and there is fire there or every day
let's go let's go yeah
because we can forest on the both sides
it runs very dangerous because of this
sub push what's up akiba answer number
you have a poll showed up especially
right yeah we are near the debaltsevo
and there are many people with guns
around saving our life
organized in our secure mark sadistic
parroquia de para cada año festival
Giada you see em this year but luckily
me eternally oversized FPS our status
the invitation is ours it out itonus
prostitution keep up with the keeper
silky must be Tammy speaks Mojave Desert
California movado merfolk superhero a
close to fort keys jingle I can I can
positive images systems are you single
I feel like we done almost everything
what plant that's good I'm sure that
that's very important for guys here that
we come that you remember about them
that we bring too much love from the
cities to them for they could feel that
they on the right place and that they
have to stay here they have to defend us
I hope that all finished and we can come
back for our usual life usual of
occasions usual cinema bars and all the
stuff because now we can't relax you
know it's as a volunteer I can't relax
stay in even still in Kiev would last
thank you emotional it's hard when you
come back it's very hard for me probably
because you gave what emotions and
I no love from your heart every trip you
like living part of of your heart there
to to these guys who stay there in such
weather in such a fire
and you continue thinking about them you
know all the time